so hello everybody welcome to my talk so
I'm going to talk about detecting
duplicate questions in Korra so I think
all of you know Korra I'll start with
some basic stuff then I would like to go
deeper and some of you might know that
there was a competition on Kaggle that
ended a few weeks back I'm not going to
talk about it I'm I'm going to talk
about like I'm just I have just like a
couple of points to mention in the end
that's it
but I'm not going to talk about the
cackle competition I'm trying like more
like a generic way to do semantic
matching so let's start so I'm a data
scientist I like scikit-learn and Kara's
an extra boost in Python that's in the
order the recruiters asked me if you
know scikit-learn extra boost then they
ask me if I know Python so that's the
same order and yeah I don't like a fun
Excel it's not like I hate them I just
don't like them oh no I hate hate them
so now let's look at the problem I'm
going to talk about today Kerra
it's a question answer website driven by
the community so use this ask question
and other users provide answers so it's
fun to use when you have a lot of
important things to do and you want to
progress in it and as of March this year
Cora had 13 million questions and I
found this in one of Cora answers so I
don't know if I can trust that so with
with so many questions it's obvious that
there's going to be a lot of duplicates
and it's it's it's not a good idea to
store the duplicates and ask uses for to
answer those triplicate questions again
so better to cluster them and merge them
so in late January Cora releases first
dataset public dataset and my face was
like that so I was
I'm very excited I wanted to play with
it the data contained a set of duplicate
and non duplicate questions and we can
now look at the data first have you guys
seen this data by the way No
so there are some duplicate questions
they have the same same meaning but
different words are used so what
practical applications might evolve from
discovery of fix boson or practical
benefits of discovery of Higgs boson why
did Trump win the presidency or how did
even the presidential residency thus
initial election so kind of same meaning
so these these are from the data set and
then there are non duplicate questions
so like somebody is asking about how can
can apply in Mozilla and about the car
so they are entirely different the
second one is about mr. robot but
they're entirely different questions
the third one it's like somebody wants
to start an e-commerce website and what
he should do about it and the other part
is which web technology is suitable to
start a ecommerce website so these are
non duplicate some of the sample so
actual data set consists of four hundred
thousand more than 400 thousand question
payers like these the data that Korah
extracted was very skewed so it had a
lot of positive samples positive samples
meaning a lot of duplicates and very
less negative samples so what they did
was when you go to Korah you can see
like you have a question and there they
have related coefficients next to them
so they added related questions as non
duplicates so there the data was not
skewed any more in that much and yeah
then we can like there is a lot of noise
in the data and they also mention that
it's not the real distribution that you
see on the Korah website of course so
this is this is one of those snapshots
of the data so like two hundred fifty
five thousand negative samples and one
49,000 positive samples so 40%
approximately positive sample
the snapshot I took I was like first few
who were all non duplicates so no
duplicate so see there so I started with
some now now we can like to dig into the
data so I started with some very basic
statistics like average number of
characters and question 1 the minimum
number of characters so we can see that
maximum number of characters in question
1 is half of maximum number of
characters the question to almost and
average number is same some questions
has only one character I don't know why
maybe a question mark so yeah I mean
these are these are also started with a
very basic feature engineering I think I
don't need to explain this but I'll just
go through it very fast so what is the
length of question 1 similarly for
question 2 difference in the two lengths
character length of question 1 without
spaces same for question 2 number of
words in both questions and the number
of common words so in Python that's very
easy to implement these features if
you're using pandas it's just like
one-liners for all of them so in the end
last one what I'm doing is just taking
in set split intersection counting the
length and that's it so it's very easy I
call this feature set 1 FS 1 so we'll
just need it to compare in the end next
thing that I found was fuzzy string
matching so it's also known as
approximate string matching and it's
calculating a distance beta based on the
primitive operations that you do in the
strings to go to make the string same
similar same as the other string that
you're comparing to so the primitive
operations are insertion you're
inserting a new character at a given
position deletion so to delete a
particular character or substitution
substituting a character with another
one and it's typically used for spell
checking ragged
detection also for DNA sequence matching
and spam filtering I plan to use these
features and will see the performance
what happens so I was like just there is
a package called fuzzy wuzzy it uses
Levenstein distance and these are the
features that I extracted so queue ratio
stands for quick ratio weighted ratio
than happy to consider a sheõs to
consult ratio and the partials of that
so there are there a few more but these
are some that I plan to use mmm great
then we have here the fuzzy features
implemented in the same way so you can
just call from fuzzy fuzzy with the
import first and then you have all the
functions just input to strings to get
the list and is calculated not so
difficult is that I'm going to discuss
also very basic and but they have been
used in all kinds of natural language
processing problems all the time so it's
mandatory to talk about them so the
fuzzy fuzzy features is access to
feature set to tf-idf so everybody knows
what tf-idf is so term frequency x
inverse document frequency and i always
use these parameters from scikit-learn
tf-idf vectorizer and they always work
it's like magic so not for English I
mean it's other language then I always
use some other stop words so the next
one was SVD features so it's also known
as latent semantic analysis and I use
the second inversion of SVD truncated
SVD with 120 components so I just use
them on top of the tf-idf features but I
use tf-idf and sweetie features in very
different ways so there are five
different ways that I thought of I
implemented them so the first one is
something like this you have the two
questions
EF IDF models separate ones and then you
have a machine learning model on top of
it the second one is combining the
questions first
so just concatenating the springs and
the tf-idf then the machine learning
model third one is similar to the first
one tf-idf done SVD I mean there's no
rocket science here fourth one is
combining the tf-idf vectors first then
SVD and fifth one combining questions
vers tf-idf and SVD but don't try this
if you don't have a lot of memory in
your computer
yeah so after this we have we have some
good good features like work to work
features so we know that everybody knows
were to occur to luminal networks take
input as text corpus and returns a
vector for every word in that purpose so
the words which have similar meaning
they cluster together they're always
close to each other and it has always
provided great insights and then happy
next sensibly used in NLP tasks these
days so I use the word to get trained on
Google News corpus 300 dimensions
moving on to word to web features that's
if you want to visualize it so every
word gets the position in space so like
Berlin Paris or France Germany and the
thing is if you subtract Germany the
vector of Germany from Berlin I add
France to it you will get some vector
which is very similar to Paris close
Paris so um yeah these are the words to
work things next thing I have before
before I go like derive features from
these were two back vectors I want
something like sentence two vector so
this is how I implemented it I'm using
Python 2 here so forgive me for that so
you have I'm using both japan either
from analytic a and
then I'm removing the stop words then
I'm checking if it's all the characters
are alphabets so if it's numeric or it's
just one character then I'm removing
them then I'm creating an array of all
the victors stacking them together and
in the end taking the sum and
normalizing it so um so yesterday I mean
I'm not very much of a applied guy
so yesterday I was talking to somebody
and the person was like I'm not going to
put any kind of mathematics in my slides
so there's some maths about the cosine
distance but yeah you guys know that dot
product and divide by the normal quality
multiplication of the norms of these two
vectors so these are some of the virtual
back features that I derived from were
two vectors similarly Manhattan distance
also known as the city block distance
calculate segregated point-wise distance
between the two vectors and yeah
similarly Canberra distance Minkowski
brake artists that's it yeah the next
features were word move or distance so
like if we're looking at these two
documents here there's nothing in common
and if you just take bag of words and do
a cosine similarity between then the
cosine distance is going to be 1.0 but
they are very very much similar to each
other
so what world move or distance does is
it adapts the earthmover distance to
space of documents so that the distance
between two texts is given by the total
amount of mass needed to move the words
from one side to another side so Obama
is close to President speaks and greets
they are close to each other so we are
we are actually minimizing this function
where T IJ is the costs or flow matrix
to move is worth two Jet's word
and CIJ is nothing but a distance
between the two vectors so if it's Obama
and president assistance and it's
subject to the constraint that the flow
the inflow should be equal to the
outflow so the words coming from
document one to document two should be
the same and document two should contain
all the words from document one so
that's the only constraints that you
have so for for this of the using Jensen
again the same googliness vectors two
more important features that I found was
where's q2 just calculating the skew of
word to work vectors for question one
and question two so zero for a normal
distribution and if it's greater than 0
it implies that more weight is on the
left of the left tail of the
distribution and the second was with
ketosis so I I don't even understand the
maps inside that so I just use it I use
the Fisher version because that was
default so now you have you have all
these features coming from hi pack and
you have the different some some
distance features that I didn't discuss
because of the mathematics involved and
you have skew and kurtosis so let's see
some of the raw over to work features on
the Korra data it looks like this can
you guys see it so like here on the left
hand side we have download website music
etc they are clustered together and here
we have President Trump and Hillary are
together
haha and yeah India and Pakistan or else
together so good enough so finally to
summarize the features we have like
these features that I calculated this is
snapshot of the features that we have
the length features common words fuzzy
features and this one is or like
distance features cue and kurtosis
and then we can go into building machine
learning models so one of the features
we have already created and I went with
two of my favorites logistic regression
and extra boost
I used five fold cross validation
stratified splits so a ratio positive to
negative sample is same in each split
I used accuracy as a comparison
comparison metric I was also looking at
precision and recall so why I chose
accuracies because cora engineering in
their blog they explained that they use
accuracy for this task also there are
some papers which are using this data
and I wanted to compare to them so
that's why I was using accuracy so these
are some of the results here so starting
with the very basic features we have
accuracy of 0.65 eighth and yeah it
keeps on increasing as you keep on
adding more and more features so the
basic features fuzzy features work to
make features and draw what two vectors
these gave 0.8 one for accuracy using Xu
boost
I didn't even bother to train it with
lodged aggravation it was a huge matrix
lot of features and here we can see like
cloth segregation performs better than
Xu boost so only case it's the tf-idf
and SVD so here
forty percent so forty percent positive
samples I think I mentioned it in the
beginning I'll start again
forty percent positive samples we had a
good recap and features snapshots yeah
so the accuracy was eighty one point
four percent using extra boost that not
I didn't bother to do a lot of hyper
parameter optimization was taking a lot
of time anyways so maybe we can improve
the results so to improve the accuracy
we can use some deep learning techniques
but before we start with the deep
learning models and if I show you my
deep learning model we can just go
through some general terms that I that
will come up so Alice Thames so there
are two ways to feed a time series data
into neural networks you can either have
a network for every time step you use or
you can use the windowed approach so the
windowed approaches answered by Ella
schemes long short-term memories its
type of recurrent networks that learns
long term dependencies and it was
invented in 1997 by Schmitt Hoover and
has been extensively used in NLP tasks
since then so the next thing that I use
I'll talk about it it's one dimensional
Congress so this layer creates a
convolutional kernel that is convolved
with the layer input over a single
temporal dimension to produce tensor of
output it's very easy to understand so I
need to implement also
where is my mouse yeah next thing is
embedding layers so like you have word
columns you want to convert them to word
vectors yeah I think I forgot to mention
I'm using Kira's for everything then we
have time distributor dense layer secure
as as a time distributed dense wrapper
and if you use the wrapper on any layer
it applies the layer to every temporal
slice of the input so I use this wrapper
around the dense layers and Kira's and
that's why it's time distribute dense so
it's followed by lambda architecture
lambda layer and it implements the
translation layer I don't know if you
guys know about the SNL I model so it's
implementing the same thing and it's
implemented in this way so you have the
embedding I've been using in in varying
matrix I'll come back to that later time
distributed dense and in the original
SNL I go they are using Mac's I think
I'm just doing a song because it
performed better for me jovem bearings
so it's a count based model which string
damage narrator Egyptian on
co-occurrence count matrix so you have
word context matrix word in context and
which one factorize gives you the word
feature matrix so I use the common crawl
pre-trained the vectors to eight hundred
forty billion tokens victor size of five
hundred three hundred dimensions yeah
and my basis of my deep learning model
was this so the SNL I think so you have
the premise and hypothesis and it has
three classes in my case I have only one
two classes and it's a very small neural
network
so yes with the translation layer that I
explained earlier so let's see some of
the necessary steps taken before
building the model so you have to
tokenize the data first first of all you
have to convert the text to number
sequences and I use Kira's tokenizer for
that so keeping a limit of two hundred
thousand words and maximum number of
words 240 and then you have to pack the
sequences so that the sequences are of
the same size so next step is loading
the embedding itself it's just loading
in the dictionary no rocket science then
we have to create the embedding matrix
so we have the dictionary of vectors and
we have the words from the tokenizer so
just grabbing the words and getting a
dictionary now we can finally take a
look at the deep learn deep net model so
this is my deep net molar it's pretty
simple so I have six models in this
actually seven and the last one is a
think it's not even readable but we'll
see that so so it's huge it's not small
and since its use we look at it part by
part so starting with the model one and
model two these are my time distributor
dense layers on both of them both the
questions so we have the embedding
matrix an embedding layer here
initializing it with the weights drove
vector weights and the input length is
40 as previously and it's non trainable
and it outputs a three and the dimension
vector and similarly for the second
model then we have the 1d CNN's looks
something like this and we are embedding
then convolutional one dealer a global
max cooling dropout dense dropout and a
patch normalization layer
it's something like this so it's very
easy to implement and Kiera's then comes
to LF team leaders so the thing here is
I'm not using any kind of pre trained
embeddings here I'm learning them from
scratch and then we can have we have
finally the dense layers so all of the
material dimensions with free Lu
activation and drop out and patch
normalization I think there are four or
five system the total number of
parameters in this network are 174
million and I was using a Titanic's to
train this network so now we can we can
just go for training the network and we
can wait the training can begin so it
took around 300 seconds for every epoch
and we can compare it with our previous
results so the whole model takes around
10 to 15 hours to Train on Titan acts
and this achieves the accuracy of almost
85% which beats extra boost so we can of
course we can improve the results
further we can do some kind of data
cleaning like correcting misspellings
part-of-speech tagging we can do so
nouns were very important that I found
out later on and entity recognition also
combining deep net with traditional
machine learning models doing a lot of
on something and stuff if you want to so
this was the timeline so kora release
the data search here on 24th of Jan is
this thing on 27th of February when
cattle started the competition on the
same data set on 16 of March and this
was my frustration plot because it was
not about natural language processing in
the ends it was more about the magic
features and they were introducing magic
features one by one so I'm not talking
about casual competition
yeah so to end the talk I think I'm on
time the deep net gives near
state-of-the-art results and the
state-of-the-art models by MBM
it has accuracy of 88% right now and you
can also take a look at these references
that I used and thank you very much the
code is available so have fun
[Applause]
can you hear me sure okay it's all it's
on okay thanks for the talk I didn't
understand that one bit when used keys
used a time-based layer or something to
do with time time distributed yeah
there's no time tagging in this is this
so why did you use I mean I have no clue
what that is by the way I just didn't
understand that part about the time
similarly as you since you can use Ellis
teams they work in the same way so I'm
just using them for NLP so for the text
data so it has nothing to do with
triangle happening out in just at all
time derivative thanks
you
did you win in Kaggle i was 16th out of
3000 people so that's something
congratulations
I don't see a lot of effort what does it
take to win I don't know never won
thanks Mazz presentation I'm just
curious with something when you show the
embedding layer you set the input length
to 40 so yeah I just missed that detail
so that 40 was the maximum number of
words that each question head or you
just cut some of the words I just got
some of the words and how did you do
that just randomly or I did some tests
and then I came up with so I tried 1640
performace cutter
okay I just ran I just you know this is
getting at the end of the sentence
beginning of the sentence randomly or
it's cutting and the end of the scent
and the end of the sentence okay just
one more thing did you look at the
precision and recall my quest to know if
you are which one which class you are
missing I did but I don't remember okay
but I'll run the same thing again and
I'll put it on my github just yeah just
cool but nice work I really really
enjoyed
hi in great top so you had for a deep
kind of last layer so how did the
performance kind of what was the trend
of the performance versus the depth
could you like add more stacks more
layers with it in crystal form so by the
time I was publishing this a lot of
people had already worked on it and they
told me that drop out also doesn't work
batch normalization doesn't work so they
were just using dense layers but for me
somehow it worked and I kept on adding
layers and till like five layers it was
pretty good and and eventually it kind
of converges there was no point like in
anymore
so the training training accuracy is
always increasing and it should and this
validation accuracy takes a plateau nice
talk
I very much enjoyed it I have a question
you know at some point I tried something
that has some some similarities with
with this so I for inputting up for an
input phrase I search for the most the
closest one in niches complete work so
input I don't know I want an apple so
what in within niches work is most
similar to this and not worth to work
and all these sort of things and again I
was thinking about extending this with a
part of speech recognitions and it was
just one of the things in the slide
before this and how would you use those
so you would you identify verbs and find
the words of X similarities in verbs or
more
a complex approach so in the competition
thing what I did was use the nouns and
works and then their work were to occur
presentations then create features from
them add to the model so that's what I
did
but you can you can use a different ways
okay quick question with a big answer
probably so could you go more in depth
into the decision you made in the model
itself because it's a huge model so I'm
sure you made a lot of decisions good
question and a short answer throws back
it again though on the wall and see what
sticks what do you mean by that
I just tried some random models from
like small layers and kept on adding
more layers see how the performances
kept on increasing the width of the
neural net so I tried around 10 to 15
models something like that and yet this
one performed the best and then I was
also frustrated of training so yeah
thank you
you mentioned or I took from what you
talked about that after the first batch
of models you put lots of work into
making models a couple of percentages
better and then in the last slide you
mentioned things like cleaning mistakes
in the data do you think with high night
time it's better to stop at the rough
model and try to get more or better data
yeah well it's better to to model even
so when when I started this I was not
doing the competition thing I was just
doing it for fun and trying to make it
as close to the state-of-the-art thing
so still missed it by three percent so
that was my target that's it and yeah I
I didn't say that
there were mistakes in cleaning but you
can you can maybe you can improve it by
cleaning it more because there were a
lot of messes belling's in the data set
I just have one question did you have
issues because you used like a pre tango
direct model did you have issues with
with unknown words you know them oh I
ignored them you ignore that so that's
why I miss correcting the misspellings
is going to maybe it's going to perform
that have you like a ratio of I know
where I I don't know okay just ignore
them
okay thanks
[Applause]